[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
June 22nd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
financial apps make it easy to quickly
log in and check your 401k balance Wall
Street Journal reporter Anne turkusen is
here to tell us why Financial experts
say checking too often could hurt your
retirement portfolio long term so Anne
why are people so eager to check their
401ks right now after having been in a
bear Market there's a certain excitement
to a bull market you know you get sort
of a dopamine hit when you look at your
401k balance as opposed to you know
during a bear Market where you log on
and you're probably pretty nervous it's
a different set of emotions it's a much
more positive set of emotions this is a
real rush I think there probably can be
you know depending on the person but yes
so how do these frequent check-ins now
compare to how often investors check
their balances when the markets weren't
riding so high so Vanguard it has some
interesting data they serve as an
administrator for you know millions of
401k participants out there and
according to their data a little over 60
percent of participants checked their
accounts in 2022 and that's when the s p
was in a bear Market but in contrast
when we were in a bull market in 2019
2020 and 2021 the percentages checking
were closer to 70 percent so it's not a
huge difference but it's notable and
they know when people are checking their
balances they can track if you come in
through the phone if you come in and you
check on your computer and if you check
on mobile there are a couple different
ways that people access their accounts
and yes they can track that so what's
the harm in logging in and checking your
balances you spoke to behavioral
economists why do they advise against
checking balances so frequently
especially in the bull market when
people check very often they can
subsequently engage in sub-optimal
behaviors there are academic studies
that show that the more people look get
their 401ks the lower their long-term
returns are likely to be and there are
some pretty influential seminal studies
that have shown that in fact that's the
case what's that connection between
checking and then lower long-term
results well it depends but during a
bull market people who check often
perhaps feel wealthier and even though
that money is locked up in an account
that's for retirement psychologically
you feel wealthier so you might be more
likely to just spend more money which
can lead to lower savings rates there's
also the effect of if you look and you
see that stocks are doing well it can
encourage people to really raise their
asset allocation towards stocks to
become more heavily exposed to stocks
and that's fine except that if if we
have like a sell-off that comes along or
a bear market then going into it you're
sort of Overexposed to stocks which can
magnify your losses during a bear Market
the op opposite can happen or people who
check too often get concerned because
they see negative numbers they see their
balance going down and those people can
start to feel maybe overly nervous about
holding stocks so they'll back away from
stocks and they'll sell their stocks at
a time when prices are down which is not
what you want to do so you want to be
selling when prices are up it just
encourages counterproductive buying and
selling activity a moment ago you
mentioned checking your balances on your
phone or a mobile device and it's pretty
easy to log in and check your balance
just a couple of swipes and keystrokes
on your device why does that ease of
accessibility concern behavioral
economists in particular there is data
that shows that people who check on
mobile devices check more often it's
just easier right I mean you sort of
Almost mindlessly Do all sorts of
activities on your phone so if checking
your 401k balances among them then it
just means that that's going to be
something that you're doing more often
and the data shows that people who check
more often tend to have lower returns so
it just kind of sets you up for
temptation to do things that might end
up being counter and productive all
right so how frequently should someone
check their balance so you know I asked
a bunch of people behavioral economists
and you know people who are experts on
investing how often do you guys check
and how often should people check and
there is no simple answer there's no
simple rule of thumb some people I mean
myself for example I can't avoid
checking because when I log on to
another account my health savings
account that I often have to do sort of
administrative things with my 401k
balance is linked to it so it's just
right there for me to see it I try not
to look I try not to have it register in
my brain but there's a researcher who's
really quite influential in the
retirement space he says he checks once
a year once a year he will go through
and he will check all of his accounts
and he will write down the balance and
it's a way for him of keeping track of
where he stands someone else I spoke to
said she just kind of checks
occasionally most people seem to agree
that maybe checking four times a year at
most is kind of what they would
recommend and if you can prevent
yourself from checking more than once a
year then that's probably even better I
mean as you get closer to retirement
people tend to check more and often for
good reason because they really have to
figure out okay I'm thinking about
retiring can I actually afford to do
this yeah it is hard to look away
especially when times are good but what
else can someone focus on or what can
they do rather than just looking at
their 401k if you find yourself check
talking out of an anxiety type of
reaction or just sort of mindlessly you
should probably ask yourself what is it
that you really want what are you really
trying to accomplish by looking if you
just looked two days ago what are you
trying to accomplish by looking again
today and often it's that people feel
that they're sort of seeking a sense of
control or they have some kind of
anxiety that's being channeled into this
behavior and for people who are in that
situation it could be that their anxiety
is you know about money and in that case
having some kind of formal financial
plan can actually help relieve some of
that anxiety people feel that they're
more in control when they work with a
professional to come up with a financial
plan where there's a sort of a
recommended savings rate that actually
makes sense for them given their goals
and the number of years they have until
retirement so you can't control the
market that's the reality right so
people feel some sense of anxiety about
that but you can control your savings
rate so that's the idea with having like
an actual financial plan that's
formulated by somebody who does this all
the time who knows what they're doing
that's Wall Street Journal of retirement
reporter Ann Ferguson and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]